a day after a Russian military plane
crashed here not far from the border
with Ukraine there's a growing list of
questions but few answers why for
example asked the Ukrainian government
has Russia which normally documents
prisoner exchanges like this one not
released any
images if the Russians had any
photographs or video they could show the
location of our prisoners of War they
would have done so
already Ukraine has also called for
Russia to allow access for a full
International investigation of the crash
accusing Moscow of a long-standing
campaign of
disinformation I think it's Russian
propaganda they want to undermine us I
don't believe our prisoners were on
board there weren't enough bodies
recovered from the site in a country
that's deeply suspicious of any
information coming out of Moscow there
are continuing doubts about the
reliability of the list of the 65
Ukrainian prisoners of war and a senior
spokesperson for military intelligence
here has questioned just how many people
were on board claiming only five bodies
have been delivered to a local Mor the
same official has also claimed Russian
intelligence agents prevented a group of
VIPs from boarding the doomed aircraft
before takeoff for many in Ukraine doubt
surrounding the crash is evidence of a
general lack of information about
Ukrainian prisoners of
War uh we need uh uh an access to real
information we need to know for for the
sake of justice and some humanitarian um
law and I mean the global values
definitely uh we need this access as a
like as a right and as a principle for
relatives of the estimated 8,000 PS the
growing doubts add to existing anxieties
Rob McBride Al jazer
Kei make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz